because you do a lot of things you
obviously do you produce your own music
as well
so i've gotten into music production and
i've made some of my own tracks in the
past
but for this um i i really
want wanted to put emphasis on quality
and i don't think that i'm
in terms of producing music at the
quality at the level of quality that i
want to be
to match my rap vocals so of course i
reached out to a producer a long time
somebody who's music i've loved for a
long time his name is kay's kokoro beats
and uh he does like dojin music and also
he's like a dj and just
dodging music yeah like touhou uh dojin
music
uh his group yeah so his so listen no no
it's a little different
no like don't you know it doesn't just
mean yeah right
it's like you're freaking me
so basically so he he runs a toho dojin
music
circle uh called tom onsen and they're
like um they do
hip-hop remixes of touhou music pretty
much okay just
just okay just to clarify just to
clarify okay
dojin in in the traditional sense just
means
fan made yes you probably need to
explain what touhou is
like it's a game
just means fan made porn damn they
really like adopted that word though
yeah yeah yeah yeah i didn't know there
was another i thought it was meant poor
so anything that's anything that's dojin
just means it's fan made like it's not
actually oh i thought it was just the
japanese word for rule 30 thought i mean
that's
that's what it is like in the west mean
i mean like like i'm going going on
a bit of a tangent yeah yeah yeah yeah
but uh i found it we'll we'll get back
and we'll get it don't worry
no don't worry at all i'll make a mental
note but like i find it super
interesting that when i
first moved to japan when we're having
conversation with a bunch of japanese
people
and we're like trying and they have like
no word for hentai you know what i mean
yeah
yeah and that was super surprising for
me where like what what
what do japanese people call hentai
because when you when you want to refer
to like animated
uh animated porn they don't they don't
have like specific words you're doing
this in conversation
you weren't there in the conversation
yeah
you were just like you were just like
mentally wait what was this when did
this happen
it was uh like outside it was like one
of the book walker parties
and i think i do remember something like
this yeah and i was just like standing
there like what is happening so cali do
you watch shantae
what a great question um no
i don't i don't know what that is thank
god all right
i see you guys
there's no need to be i don't know what
they're talking about getting back to
your music
you were talking about [ __ ] i can't
remember what you were talking about
you're talking about my
yeah yeah so basically um so i
found or i rather uh asked for some help
from one of my favorite producers
um yeah who i mentioned is in the the
touhou
dojin music circle and i wanted to pick
someone that i
whose music that i really really enjoyed
um so we just started working together
and
he's been really helpful because at the
same time i'm also trying to learn how
to mix
right and back in the day when i was
doing my own independent stuff
um i got decent at it like okay but
there's always this feeling of like ah
this could be better and if i do it
myself
it's not gonna be the level that i know
that it can be right so
so we'd work on it together and i would
mix the initial file
send it over to him and then he would
fix it up and like you know tell me what
tell me what he did
and like uh that kind of thing and yeah
kind of a collaborative effort right so
i can kind of learn a bit
see what he changed etc and get better
but also put out a quality product
i guess yeah because i mean you've done
you've you've you said you're producing
your own music as well and you've done
animation you mentioned earlier
like is all this self-taught uh you have
any background in it
um so when i went to reaper school i did
do a little focus
on drawing specifically um i went
i went and i studied comics actually
comic writing
yes and a little bit of animation
as well but that was that was mainly
what i wanted to do
aside from reaping of course but um yeah
i would say that was my focus but then
of course things changed dramatically
when i realized i wanted to do music
um and it was pretty pretty late in the
game i would say to be honest i
i had finished my my schooling and
whatnot but when i realized what i
really wanted to do and i was like oh
[ __ ]
what have i done what have i done i've
existed this long and i'm now realizing
that i want to do something else
and then i started doing the music thing
and realized oh
i'm better at music than i am at drawing
and reaping literally
everyone who goes to uni literally our
entire lives
i feel like you go to university to
figure out what you 100 don't want to do
yeah yeah which is normally the subject
i mean it's normally the case where if
you're forced to study something for
three four five years you normally have
a good inkling by the end of it
whether you want to do it or not right
and a lot of times when you're like
[ __ ]
forced to pick something when you're 18
you're like maybe i'll maybe i could be
you know maybe i'll be good doing this
yeah most of the time you've got to get
that choice wrong
right of course of course yeah because i
don't know a single person who like
actually graduated from
like a degree of any kind and actually
went into that field immediately
afterwards like i feel that's pretty
rare i mean of course it's not
it's not zero definitely but like i know
a lot of people who just
went into completely different job yeah
right